Varys: The coin of Aerys, Second of His Name,
had landed on madness.
But half the coins of the Targaryens had landed
so.
Yet only Aerys would be known as the Mad King,
thanks, in no small part, to the Defiance
of Duskendale.
Duskendale was the greatest port on Blackwater
Bay until Aegon built King's Landing.
As the capital grew richer and more prosperous,
it sucked ships and gold away from Duskendale.
To halt its long decline, the Lord of Duskendale,
Ser Denys Darklyn, petitioned King Aerys for
a royal charter that would allow him to levy
his own port fees and taxes, which would obviously
be lower than in King's Landing.
The Hand of the King, Tywin Lannister, refused.
But knowing of the tension between the Hand
and its king, Ser Denys invited the king to
Duskendale to evaluate his petition himself
rather than deferring to his Hand.
When Tywin admonished the king to refuse,
as any sensible advisor would, a petulant
and bristling Aerys instead accepted, traveling
to Duskendale with a small retinue and only
one of his Kingsguard.
As soon as Aerys stepped within the city,
Ser Denys seized him, killing the Kingsguard
and the few others who dared to defend their
king.
Aerys was hauled to the dungeons to have his
beard pulled and have other petty cruelties
inflicted on his royal person.
Lord Tywin immediately raised an army and
marched on Duskendale, but Ser Denys threatened
to kill the king at the first signs of an
assault.
If Ser Denys hoped to force Tywin to offer
terms, he didn't know Lord Tywin, who refused
to even parley until Ser Denys released the
king and surrendered.
The royal army surrounded the city, and the
royal navy blockaded it.
Ser Denys had clearly not anticipated such
obstinacy.
Nor that the king's Hand would be in no rush
to save the maddening king, when, as Lord
Tywin himself pointed out, the realm had a
better option in the king's much more stable
son, Prince Rhaegar.
After six months, Lord Tywin's patience was
at an end.
Or, at least, none could claim he acted recklessly
if he now stormed the city, and Ser Denys
killed the king.
But the dutiful and honorable Ser Barristan
the Bold volunteered to infiltrate the city
and rescue his king single-handedly, as befit
his Kingsguard oath.
Tywin couldn't refuse such valor publicly
and so begrudged Ser Barristan one night.
Then he would storm the city and put every
man, woman, and child to the sword.
With only his hands, Ser Barristan climbed
the city walls in the dark of night and snuck
through the city disguised as a beggar, evading
patrols and suspicious townspeople.
When he reached the walls of the city keep,
the Dun Fort, he scaled those by hand as well,
even dispatching the wall guard before he
could sound an alarm.
With incredible bravery and luck, Ser Barristan
made his way to the dungeons and freed his
king.
Then Ser Barristan's luck ran out.
A cry went up through the castle.
Someone had discovered the king was gone.
With horns and trumpets blaring an alarm,
Ser Barristan cut their way to the stables,
avenging his slain Kingsguard brother but
taking an arrow to his chest.
Slipping through the castle gate just as it
closed, the wounded Ser Barristan and Aerys
rode through the roused town, racing for the
city walls and, beyond it, the safety of the
royal army.
Lord Tywin's archers raced forward to clear
the walls of defenders, and Ser Barristan
the Bold earned immortality by delivering
King Aerys to the waiting, if not welcoming,
arms of his Hand.
Without his hostage, Ser Denys surrendered
and begged mercy from the same king he'd imprisoned.
Most men would have had none.
Aerys had less.
He commanded Ser Denys be executed along with
man, woman, or child who bore his family name
and anyone who once had.
As for Ser Denys's foreign wife, who had urged
his defiance, Aerys commanded that her tongue
and womanly parts be torn out, and she be
burned alive.
It was his first time passing such a sentence.
It must have given him a taste for it.
For the king rescued from Duskendale was not
the same king who'd entered it.
Many men would crack after six months in a
dark cell, being mocked, prodded, and tweaked.
Aerys had arrived cracked.
Now he was shattered.
For years, he would refuse to leave the Red
Keep.
Encouraged no doubt by his worried advisors,
since he also refused to allow any blades
near his person, even to shave his beard,
cut his hair, and trim his nails.
He began to see enemies in every shadow, who
vanished only when the fires burned.
Robert Baratheon: Aerys Targaryen was the
last of his name to sit on the Iron Throne.
Known far and wide as "the Mad King," his
was a reign of instability and terror.
The Seven Kingdoms are well-rid of him and
his kind.
Oh, he may have appeared to be a capable ruler
at first, but that was due in no small part
to his councilors led by the Hand of the King,
Tywin Lannister.
There may have been years of peace and prosperity
during Aerys's reign, but it was Tywin who
was really running the country as Aerys spiraled
further and further into insanity.
The dragonspawn were famous for losing their
minds.
It was the price they paid for centuries of
keeping the bloodlines pure.
And Aerys more than happily continued the
noble tradition of his forefathers.
As the years passed, Aerys's behavior became
increasingly erratic.
He cut himself so often on his Iron Throne,
many referred to him as "King Scab," though
never to his face.
It was rumored he had developed an obsession
with wildfire, and was known to inflict horrific
punishments on those he considered enemies,
including burning them alive.
As his paranoia and bloodlust grew, he had
a bitter falling out with Lord Tywin, who
had served the Crown faithfully for twenty
years.
At least Tywin was able to leave the job with
his life and fortunes intact.
Subsequent Hands of King Aerys weren't so
fortunate.
Then the Targaryens went too far.
The Crown Prince, Rhaegar, abducted Lyanna
Stark, daughter of Rickard Stark, the Lord
of Winterfell.
She was my betrothed.
She was my beloved — beautiful and spirited
woman.
And I loved her more than life itself.
Rhaegar went south with Lyanna, hiding her
away in Dorne.
What harm he inflicted on the poor girl, the
gods only know.
Brandon Stark, Lyanna's eldest brother, was
outraged.
He rode to King's Landing to confront the
king and demand his sister's safe return.
Instead, Aerys had him executed.
His father, Rickard Stark, as well.
There wasn't much left to discuss after that.
Aerys feared their loved ones would seek revenge
for what he did.
He was right to be afraid.
Aerys wasted no time in calling for the heads
of Brandon's younger brother, my friend Eddard
Stark, and my head, too, of course.
I'm sorry he didn't come looking for it himself.
Alongside Jon Arryn of the Vale (the man who
fostered Ned and I as children), Baratheons,
Starks, and Tullys all called their banners.
Once our rebellion began, the Mad King's days
were numbered.
Maester Luwin: As word of King Aerys's erratic
and troubling behavior spread throughout the
Seven Kingdoms, Lord Rickard Stark continued
to serve his king faithfully as Warden of
the North.
The proud father of four children, his daughter
Lyanna was engaged to Robert Baratheon, the
young lord of Storm's End.
Centuries of peace between the North and the
Iron Throne ended the day Rhaegar Targaryen,
Prince of Dragonstone, abducted Lyanna.
Enraged, Brandon Stark rode to King's Landing
demanding the release of his sister and the
death of Rhaegar.
Aerys arrested him for treason and called
his father to come to the capital to ransom
him.
When Lord Rickard complied, Aerys, now utterly
mad, arrested him for treason as well.
Lord Rickard demanded a trial by combat.
Aerys declared fire the champion of House
Targaryen and had Lord Rickard suspended from
the rafters of the throne room while pyromancers
lit a blaze beneath him.
As he burned, Brandon was brought into the
throne room, a leather cord attached to a
strangulation device was wrapped around his
neck.
Aerys told Brandon his father was a dead man,
but there was a chance to save him.
A longsword was placed on the floor just out
of Brandon's reach.
And the more he struggled to reach it, the
more the cord tightened around his throat.
Brandon Stark strangled himself, trying to
free his father, who was roasted alive in
his own armor.
The entire court stood and watched this atrocity
take place, Ser Jaime Lannister and the Kingsguard
among them.
The Mad King was reported to have laughed
hysterically as these two noble men were tortured
and brutally killed before him.
Seeking to rid the world of all his supposed
enemies, Aerys called for the head of Rickard's
youngest son, Eddard Stark, and Lyanna's betrothed,
Robert Baratheon.
He sent word to Lord Jon Arryn, who had fostered
both young men at the Eyrie, to apprehend
them.
Instead, Lord Arryn joined Houses Stark and
Baratheon in rebellion.
Robert vowed to kill Rhaegar Targaryen and
get his beloved Lyanna back.
Tywin Lannister: As Aerys Targaryen's behavior
grew more and more erratic, the task of ruling
the Seven Kingdoms fell to me, Tywin Lannister.
I had served Aerys for nearly twenty years
and as a result, the realm had prospered.
The royal coffers were full, the land was
at peace.
But Aerys grew increasingly hostile, jealous
of the success many credited to me.
My power and influence unnerved him.
The captain of my personal guard, Ser Ilyn
Payne, was once overheard making offhand comments
regarding who was the true ruler of Westeros.
When the king was given this information,
he had llyn Payne's tongue ripped out with
hot pincers.
It was my desire to unite the Houses of Lannister
and Targaryen through marriage.
My daughter, Cersei, would marry Aerys's eldest
son, Prince Rhaegar.
Such a union made perfect sense for all parties.
However, Aerys's senses had begun to leave
him quite sometime earlier.
Instead of uniting the royal family with its
most loyal and powerful ally, Aerys chose
instead to insult my family, indicating that
such a match was beneath Rhaegar.
Instead, he chose Elia Martell of Dorne to
be Rhaegar's wife.
As if to rub salt in my wounds, Aerys appointed
Jaime, my son, to the Kingsguard.
The Kingsguard may be an honor for lesser
families than ours, but it is a lifetime appointment
that forces him to renounce all family holdings.
This creates a difficulty in naming an heir
to Casterly Rock.
But Aerys knew all that.
I had grown tired of the king's constant provocation.
Thus I resigned my post as Aerys's Hand and
returned to Casterly Rock with my considerable
forces.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled against the
throne, Aerys grew fearful that I would join
with Robert's forces and rise against him.
He thought himself clever and kept Jaime very
close as if warning me.
He sunk deeper and deeper into delusion, paranoia,
and violence.
I've heard it said he became obsessed with
wildfire, a substance which, once lit, cannot
be extinguished.
Convinced he had enemies all around him, he
wouldn't allow blades in his presence, save
for those of his Kingsguard.
Alas, that proved to be his undoing.